Success is failing over and over again without losing enthusiasm.
I pretty much believe in that.
To me, practice is purposeful, intentional iterations of failure.
You need those moments of struggle in order to come back up,...
...realizing that, "Hey, if I come out of this, I'm actually stronger."
That's motivating.
The things that have motivated me every day have changed over the years.
Before, it was getting the medals or getting the records.
And now, it's almost like there's this intangible something that's bigger than me.
Something that inspires me the most...
...is people who do something that's never been done.
And every attempt, every day, it's part of my pursuit.
How good can I be?